>> I THINK GOD CALLS ALL OF US
TO FILL DIFFERENT ROLES AT
DIFFERENT TIMES, AND I THINK
THAT HE WANTED DONALD TRUMP TO
BECOME PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: I WONDER IF GOD
WANTED ME TO DO THIS JOB.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
THE DEVIL MADE YOU DO THIS.
THESE EGGS DEMOCRATS AND THE
MEDIA MOCKING SARAH SANDERS FOR
THAT COMMENT.
>> NO, HE DIDN'T.
EVEN GOD WAS LIKE WHAT THE HELL,
I CAN'T TAKE MY EYES OFF YOU.
>> IF HE DID, HE WANTED TO
PUNISH US FOR TAKING OUR
DEMOCRACY FOR GRANTED.
THIS PRESIDENT IS THE ANTITHESIS
OF JESUS CHRIST'S TEACHINGS.
>> I BELIEVE GOD CALLED ME TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE KNOW
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT THE DUDE.
>> Jesse: SANDERS TAKING AIM
AT THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORPS
FOR GRANDSTANDING DURING
BRIEFINGS.
>> THIS ISN'T EVERYBODY AND I
DON'T WANT TO GENERALIZE THE
CROWD.
YOU SEE A LOT OF, LIKE, ANGRY
FACES.
PEOPLE, THEIR SOLE PURPOSE IS TO
FIND THIS MOMENT TO CATCH YOU.
THEIR JOB IS NOT TO GET
INFORMATION WHICH IS WHAT THE
BRIEFING IS SUPPOSED TO BE.
IT IS TO TRIP YOU UP.
I THINK IF THE BRIEFING LOSES
PURPOSE AND IT ISN'T A GOOD
RESOURCE FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO GET INFORMATION AND ANSWERS
TO REAL QUESTIONS, THEN YOU DO
HAVE TO WONDER IF ASKED THE BEST
FORUM IN ORDER TO PUT A MESSAGE
OUT.
>> Jesse: GOING BACK TO THE
TOP, GREG, I BET THE MEDIA IS
THANKING GOD EVERY DAY TERMS AS
PRESIDENT.
WE WORK ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THEY ARE MAKING MORE MONEY THAN
EVER.
THE PUBLISHING INDUSTRY
ESPECIALLY.
IT'S OKAY FOR THEM TO MAKE JOKES
ABOUT IT, THEY WERE PRETTY
FUNNY, BUT IT SEEKS AN EXAMPLE
OF THE MEDIA MOCKING A CHRISTIAN
DISPLAYING THEIR FAITH OPENLY
WHEN WE KNOW THEY WOULD DARE NOT
DO THAT IF SHE HAD CITED THE
MUSLIM GOD OR A BUDDHIST PROPHET
MUSLIM GOD OR A BUDDHIST PROPHEO
MUSLIM GOD OR A BUDDHIST PROPHER
WHATEVER.
IF SHE HAD GONE IN ANY OTHER
DIRECTION, IF ANYBODY ELSE HAD
DONE THAT, IT NEVER WOULD'VE
HAPPENED.
I THINK SHE PROBABLY MEANT HE
WAS THE RIGHT PERSON FOR THE
RIGHT TIME.
I DON'T PROFESS TO KNOW WHAT GOD
WANTS, AND I'M ALWAYS SKEPTICAL
WHEN PEOPLE SAY THAT.
>> Jesse: SHE WANTS WHAT'S
BEST FOR YOU, GREG.
>> Greg: WHEN PEOPLE CITE
RELIGION AS MOTIVATION FOR AN
ACTION, I JUST GO, YOU CAN'T
KNOW THAT.
I KNOW WHAT YOU MEAN.
YOU ARE SAYING THIS IS FOR THE
BEST.
BUT I'M ALWAYS VERY SKEPTICAL
THAT NOW I'M GOING TO SHUT UP
AND WATCH THE HATE TWEETS FLY AT
ME TELLING ME I'M GOING TO HELL.
>> Jesse: I WANTED TO GET
KATIE'S PERSPECTIVE.
CHARLIE RANGEL.
HE SAID GOD PUT OBAMA IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Katie: OBAMA SAID HE WAS
GOING TO LOWER THE SEEABLE.
I THINK OBAMA THOUGHT HE WAS
ACTUALLY GOD.
SHE HAS HER OWN BELIEFS.
THEY ARE THE BELIEFS OF MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND THE
COMEDIANS CAN MAKE FUN OF IT ALL
THEY WANT.
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO SO.
IT GOES TO SHOW THAT THEY ARE
WILLING TO CONTINUE TO INSULT
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO AGREE
WITH THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AND THE PEOPLE THAT SUPPORT
THEM.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU THINK,
JUAN?
>> Juan: I THINK YOU AND GREG
SAID THOSE ARE HER BELIEFS, LET
THEIR -- LET HER HAVE THEM.
I DON'T THINK YOU BUY IT.
THE TEN COMMANDMENTS.
OKAY TO LIE, CHEAT ON YOUR LIFE,
HANG AROUND WITH PORN STARS?
>> Greg: WHAT'S WRONG WITH
THAT LAST PART?
THAT'S NOT IN THE COMMANDMENTS.
>> Juan: WHAT ABOUT PAYING
THEM OFF WITH HUSH MONEY?
THAT'S OKAY TOO.
THE RUSSIANS, GOD BLESS THEM,
THE RUSSIANS MUST'VE BEEN
INSTRUCTED BY GOD TO GO AFTER --
>> Katie: I DIDN'T HEAR SARAH
SANDERS SAY DONALD TRUMP WAS A
PERFECTLY MORAL PERSON.
SHE SAID SHE BELIEVES GOD PUT
HIM IN PLACE TO DO THE JOB.
>> Juan: WHAT A CHOICE.
>> Jesse: WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT THE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORPS?
>> Dana: REMEMBER THE
INTERVIEW WAS GIVEN TO THE
CHRISTIAN BROADCASTING NETWORK.
>> Greg: IT'S A GOOD PIECE OF
INFORMATION.
NO ONE TOLD ME THAT.
>> Dana: SHE'S TALKING TO CBN.
WHEN GEORGE W. BUSH WAS
PRESIDENT, THEY MADE FUN OF
GEORGE W. BUSH FOR YEARS.
I CAN'T REMEMBER THE EXACT
DETAILS.
ALONG THE WAY, SOMEBODY SAID HE
FELT CALLED TO DO THIS.
IT WAS THE SAME TYPE OF
ANTIPATHY FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
CHRISTIANS.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT BUDDHISTS
BELIEVE BUT I ASSUME BUDDHIST
THINK YOU ARE IN THE RIGHT PLACE
AT THE RIGHT TIME.
ALL OF THAT.
THERE'S THAT.
THEN WHAT YOU SENT, JUAN, BUT
THE TEN COMMANDMENTS.
CHRISTIANS ALSO BELIEVE IN
FORGIVENESS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN HIS
HEART AND WHAT HE'S ASKED GOD
FOR AND WHAT SORT OF FORGIVENESS
-- NONE OF OUR BUSINESS.
THE GREAT THING IS WE DON'T HAVE
TO DECIDE.
HE GETS TO JUDGE.
>> Greg: IT COULD BE A SHE,
DANA.
>> Dana: IT COULD BE A SHE.
>> Juan: I WAS INTERVIEWING
YOUR FORMER BOSS,
GEORGE W. BUSH.
AFTERWARDS I GOT SO MUCH FLACK
FROM MY BOSSES FOR SAYING
MR. PRESIDENT, IN MY CHURCH, WE
PRAY FOR YOU EVERY SUNDAY.
PEOPLE SAID WHY WOULD YOU SAY
THAT TO GEORGE W. BUSH?
>> Dana: THIS IS THE THING.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT GEORGE W. BUSH
USED TO SAY IT WHEN WE ARE
PRAYING FOR YOU, SIR.
HE WOULD SAY THANK YOU.
I FEEL IT.
THE MEDIA WOULD MAKE FUN OF
THAT.
THE MEDIA FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS
HAS SPENT A LOT OF TIME, THEY
SENT REPORTERS OUT, GO SEE
AMERICA.
GO FIGURE OUT HOW WE GOT IT SO
WRONG.
THIS IS PART OF THE REASON WHY.
TO YOUR POINT OF WHY, IN THE
PRESS ROOM, I THINK IT'S NOT
THAT THEY ARE TRYING TO TRIP YOU
UP.
IN THE PRESS ROOM, HOW DO YOU
MAKE NEWS?
ONE OF THE WAYS YOU MAKE NEWS IS
IF YOU FIND INCONSISTENCY.
IT'S NOT THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
TELL ME THESE THINGS I WRITE
THEM DUTIFULLY DOWN AND I DON'T
GET TO ARGUE BACK.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE ROOM ARE
FRUSTRATED THAT THEY WERE CALLED
FAKE NEWS ON SOMETHING AND IT
TURNS OUT FOUR MONTHS LATER THAT
WAS TRUE.
THAT'S WHY THEY LOOK FOR
INCONSISTENCY.
THEY ARE TRYING TO BREAK NEWS.
>> Juan: MAYBE IT HURTS HER
THAT THE PRESIDENT SAYS THE
PRESS IS THE ENEMY OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Dana: I DON'T THINK IT
HURTS HER.
>> Katie: TAKE UP ALL THE